That
[Music]
Ah, my backwater fishing
connects
it. It could be philosophical to explain it. Ah, I think it
's a relationship.
That
[Music]
My name is Park Jung-hoon.
So I can't tell you the exact origin, but I'm
looking at me as safe for 3
parties.
It can
deal with large meat. It seems that there is such a difference. A
person uses power as a handle and
controls the head with some skill. The power
of the meat will be transmitted through the thin line of the line,
but the movement will
be transmitted.  Because it comes in right up to the beginning,
the subtle feeling and
the power of the meat are conveyed intact,
so it
would be nice to see it like this
.
[Music]
I'm grateful to Guk.
He gave us a taste and made us
enjoy it, but he
went beyond the desire to kill and eat the
fish.
Also, don't you
let us know about this nation, and
our ancestors, uh, about the pike fishing that our ancestors handed down?